president Trump's legal team is feuding
with the Marlow investigation over the
terms of a possible interview with the
president last night on Hannity Rudy
Giuliani said the aggressiveness of the
Muller team would backfire on them
where's the sense of justice on the part
of Muller on the part of the Justice
Department people who hate Trump will
put into primary positions of power it's
completely tainted this investigation
the real story here is not that this
case isn't gonna fizzle it's gonna blow
up on them Alan Dershowitz is a retired
Harvard Law School professor and the
author of the case against impeaching
Trump and he joins us professor is this
interview with the president going to
happen and should it happen it won't
happen I think what's going to happen is
Giuliani will make Muller an offer he
can't accept to paraphrase The Godfather
and that way Trump will be able to say
look I wanted to testify but it was
Muller who turned down a reasonable
request by our attorney look no lawyer
would ever allow a client to testify
under these circumstances all they'd
have to do was ask him one question did
you know about the meeting in the Trump
Tower with your son if he answers that
question truthfully that he didn't know
if that in fact is the truth he could
still be charged with perjury lying to a
government official because we have
Michael Cohen who says he did know and
you never allow your client to say
something that could be contradicted by
another witness because the prosecution
can choose to believe that other witness
if you had President Trump as a client
though he's a very gregarious guy who is
quite happy to sit down and talk and
chitchat to anybody and thinks that as
long as he's just like straightforward
and says what he thinks everything will
be fine often from a lawyer's point of
view that's the worst kind of client to
have isn't it yes and I would certainly
I'm not his lawyer obviously but I would
advise him to speak to the public on
television say what he wants to say
write his tweets although I don't think
he helps himself by some of his tweets
but under no circumstances put yourself
in a position where you can be charged
with perjury or lying to a federal
official and if he doesn't believe me he
should make two phone calls one to
Martha Stewart who went to jail because
of what she said to prosecutors and the
other to Bill Clinton who was impeached
because of what he said in a an
interview under oath and so I think
every responsible lawyer would say to
him you should not either testify or be
interviewed
look I once I write an advice on
television I said I have four pieces of
advice don't fire don't pardon don't
tweet and don't testify I want to ask
you about Rudy's other point which is
the hyper partisan nature of what's been
happening and with reference to this
Bruce or guy in the Justice Department
and his 60 contacts at least with
Christopher Steele the mi6 agent who was
basically the dirty tricks operative for
the Democrat Party you know as well as I
do that impartiality is the essence of
Justice a County Court judge can't have
a bunch of communications with the
plaintiff and not with the defendant
that's a big no-no how come Bruce or at
the Department of Justice doesn't know
you can't talk to one political party
can continuously through the height of a
campaign of course there's a difference
we need a judge in a prosecutor
prosecutors are allowed to talk to
people
also I don't believe that Muller and his
team care about whether the Democrats
win are the Republicans when they're not
partisan in that sense I think they are
zealous some would say overzealous
prosecutors because he's Special Counsel
he has a target on the back of the
president and others if this case were
handled by ordinary US attorneys and
they came back after a year or two years
without inviting anybody who wouldn't be
a story nobody would know but when a
special counsel is given a target and he
fails to indict he's been a failure
that's why I'm so strongly opposed to
special counsel except in the most
extraordinary circumstances which
weren't met in this case you're
absolutely right about that professor in
terms of the special counsels office I
get rid of them thanks thanks a lot